i just got back from my round two game
of the abu dhabi masters tournament and
it was a really fun one i played an
opening i've never played before
now i should note that
it's currently 1 20 p.m in abu dhabi
next round starts at 6pm
so
i could probably spend like hours
talking about this game but i'll try and
keep this brief and share some of the
key moments
so i was playing fm from india watson
singhania
and i had a little bit of time to
prepare before the game i knew that he
plays open sicilian
and i decided that i would play
um
a line that i've just never played
before the classical sicilian uh never
played this in tournament play i i
played this because uh
i knew that he could probably expect
either like a dragon or dragon dorf or
taimanov or accelerate dragon and then
he actually told me after the game that
he was preparing stafford gambit this
morning so uh it was nice to
to to play something that uh would catch
him perhaps a little bit off guard
now the move i was expecting here was
bishop e2 which uh i found that he's
played a bunch online and a few times in
tournament play as well but he played
the move bishop g5 which is the critical
main line
and um
even though this wasn't the primary move
i was expecting
i had checked this before the game
because i did find one game he had
played last year in tournament play with
this line
and i decided to go for
a pretty rare and kind of dubious tricky
variation
maybe in the same spirits as uh as a
stafford but perhaps a little bit less
dubious
uh so start with bishop d7
uh the main move by far is e6
but the point of bishop d7 is after
queen d2 black very quickly develops on
the queen side and then there's an idea
to take on d4 queen d4 and queen a5
and i discovered this
maybe about a month ago and
in preparation for the tournament
i had looked uh looked into this line
thinking that would be a kind of a cool
surprise weapon and uh it was nice to
get it in an actual game
now the point of queen a5 is to
of course attack the bishop but also
pressure uh various targets on the queen
side
and uh
here my opponent plays f4 which is most
natural by far defending the bishop
preparing e5 ideas
and uh then i unleash the move brook
takes c3 which is still preparation for
me
and if we look in the masters database
we'll find
a good handful of games
um pretty sure richard report has
been the main
player who's played this but maybe these
games i don't think the database is
updated because report has definitely
played this
uh in in like recent months or recent
years
um but the the point of rook c3 is just
to sack exchange
and
target
the e4 pawn and the line ends up being
pretty concrete
after pawn takes c3
now i should mention if queen takes c3 i
can take take and take on e4 i think
this is already very nice for black
hitting c3 threatening the fork hitting
the bishop as well
so instead my opponent
took of the pawn
and now
i have e5
and this is all still prep and we can
see by the time stamps um i really
wasn't spending too much time opening
uh yeah more time than i started with
because we do have the 30 second
increments my opponent spent uh about
eight minutes till this point and after
e5 he took uh about 40 minutes uh to
play the move
queen d3 uh so it's very long think
and
i was still in preparation so while he
was thinking i was just kind of walking
around looking at other games
because this this exact position was on
my
computer uh about half hour before the
round
and uh i will say the the main move and
the best move here is queen
b4 um and we just toggle on the engine
um
this is a dubious line for black like
engine will give plus one about for
white
but i think on a practical level
especially if white's not prepared
there's still a lot of interesting
chances for black and i'll just share
just a kind of tidbit of my preparation
i was planning to take take take
and after bishop to h4
uh my crap would continue g5 hitting the
bishop deflecting the pawn and then
bishop e7 uh is a nice move and my prep
actually kept going here uh the main
line i was looking at is bishop c4 h6
hitting the pawn uh taking advantage of
the fact the pawn is pinned and after
rook hf1 i was planning to castle here i
guess there's one game prior white is
still considered better here but
i think there's decent counter play for
black being down in exchange
so
my opponent did not go into this
but rather played queen d3
which i had very very briefly looked at
before the game
and i knew this was a playable move and
the only thing i knew about this move is
the engine will suggest knight g4 so i
played knight g4 pretty quickly
and then my opponent played queen g3
and here i was basically on my own but
uh i had a pretty good sense of what was
going on
um just given the the potential tactics
in the position
um of course i'd like to try and achieve
knight f2 and win back some material
but there's also
still a lot of juicy targets on the
queen side
and i spent a lot of time here
trying to figure out the best approach
because there's a lot of candidate moves
for black
um
like queen a2 queen a3 queen c5 queen b6
uh even h6 all of these moves were on my
radar
and
i'm going to disable engine analysis
until maybe a little bit later
but the move i ended up choosing was
queen v6
which i thought was one of the most
direct moves
simply threatening knight f2
also targeting uh just uh the weak dark
squares in white's territory
and here my opponent played bishop d3
and actually gave back material
uh i play h6
and f5
so
i should kind of explain the
what's going on here because
um
after h6 the bishop
should not move to h4
because i can take
and if queen takes her as g5 and then
this is actually like really really nice
for black i'd be getting two minor
pieces for a rook
and uh
yeah if the queen doesn't take on f4 and
queen f3 is played then g5 comes bishop
g7 this will also be nice for black so
f5 was a nice resource
essentially cutting off my bishop from
defending the knight
and um just ignoring the bishop on g5 so
it creates a situation where i could
take the bishop but then queen takes g4
and white's still up the exchange and
white should be doing very fine here
now the drawback of f5 is
i can still win back material
with knight f2
and essentially we
got to a position after bishop e3
it's very important i have knight takes
h1 attacking the queen so i'm not losing
material rook takes h1 and queen c7 got
to this position where the dust has kind
of settled
and we went from like a really chaotic
situation
to a way more positional game that's
equal material
and um
very much imbalanced just in terms of
the structure because white does have
kind of the weak double c pawns but at
the same time i'm very much
underdeveloped and i'm a little bit
stuck on the king side because the queen
is constantly eyeing the g7 pawn
which makes it very difficult to develop
the bishop and castle
now i was okay reaching this position
because
even though i'm a little bit
stuck a little bit passive
i'm also really solid and it's hard for
white to actually crack the position and
i have some initiative threatening the
pawn on c3 so my opponent played king d2
now if i'm not mistaken there was a
funny line if king b2
which also looks natural
i was looking at d5 takes and then
bishop a3 check
which i thought would be pretty cool
because king dxa3 queen c3 is mate
and uh yeah there were some other funny
lines like if king b3
uh yeah it seems like the white king is
gonna regret its life decisions here
so king d2 much more solid
and i play bishop c6
so just improving the bishop
um now the e4 pawn is somewhat of a
long-term target in white's position
because
uh the f5 pawn is a bit overextended
this pawn has to constantly be
babysitted by either the bishop or the
queen
so i was feeling pretty good here after
rook b1 i played pawn a6 ensuring
there's no bishop takes a7 also
preventing any bishop b5 potential
and here my opponent played h4
which i think is a reasonable move
there's some plans of later playing like
queen f3 and g4 g5 and
here i realize there's not really too
many options for black
uh just because yeah my bishop is still
stuck
and i decided to go for a double-edged
move
which i think in hindsight is the right
approach is to play pawn d5
and even though i'm opening the center
and i'm a little bit undevel
underdeveloped i should say
white's king is also in the center so
d5 just creates a situation where
there's going to be a bit more
sharp play for both sides
um
and i also okay i also attack the epons
so white doesn't have too many choices
here
he took i took and then c4 was played so
making my bishop retreat
and then bishop b6
and even though it looks like white has
some nice initiative and i'm kind of
getting kicked around here
i'm still very much holding on
and after c5 queen d5
i think something has already gone wrong
for white just because the bishop is a
bit out of play i have nice center queen
is aligned with the king
c5 is um now just a liability for
for white
and from here
uh we're gonna see that white's position
is really hard to hold on to
um
as we'll see in the game rook e1
uh attacking the pawn simply play f6
and now my e5 pawn my whole structure is
is very solid and i wasn't too concerned
about queen g6 here
um i could play queen f7 but
yeah during the game i was thinking even
king d7 is a nice move because the queen
can't really infiltrate and i am
threatening to take the pawn on g2
so
instead uh my opponent played king c3
which was a big surprise for me and this
just turns out to be a losing move
i think king c3 was maybe caused by
time pressure my opponent was already
falling
falling below six minutes
so i'm not sure what else white could
have done i think he had after the game
he had mentioned some kind of rookie
four idea
but uh just to show the finish king c3
things just crumble really quickly for
white
i take on c5
and the key is that after queen digs g7
i have the simple rook g8
rook is defended by the queen white's
bishop is still hanging
but more importantly after queen takes
f6
i don't take the bishop because then i
lose e5 and my queen
but here i just have a mating mat with
queen d4
and
my opponent resigned in this position
now during the game i was trying to
calculate force mate
it seemed like there were a lot of
winning options but i'm pretty sure this
is force mate
because if king b3 bishop a4 is
checkmate
and if king d2 i have rook g2
king goes back
i would have queen a1 mate and if rook
e2 i was looking at
bishop here c3 takes
king c2 bishop a4 and wherever the king
goes i wrote g1 and eventual back ring
checkmate
so
i think overall it was a nice game it
was nice to use
a somewhat tricky offbeat maybe slightly
dubious opening
but
just given the surprise value and given
my opponent wasn't
so well prepared
i think it worked out
now um it seemed like white was fine in
the middle game but i think because i i
had the nice time advantage and just
perhaps a slightly easier position to
play
yeah things just worked out for me
so
real quick i'm gonna check a few moments
with the engine
uh oh wow this is made in five was there
a quicker mate queen d4
king d2
oh bishop b4 is even quicker
force the king somewhere and then take
uh
okay so at this point it was already
winning
um i want to go back to
the moment where queen g3 was played
so it's not winning by the means for
black at this point
apparently the engine wants h6
i didn't play h6 in the game because
bishop e2
hg5 bishop takes g4
i considered this line in the game but i
thought after bishop g7
i'm still down the exchange and my king
looks awkward
but i guess my pawns are still strong
so this this could have been an
interesting line
um
oh
maybe at some point white could have
been better i mean it was very messy
position
and if we go forward here
so light was slightly better
oh white's still slightly better
ah but yeah i think bishop b6 and c5 is
probably the
the downfall for white
but still equal
oh wow so king c3 was just uh
the game losing blender now i was
already feeling comfortable at this
point
but i guess uh yeah white should have
gone for queen g6 king d7
and the game just goes on rook d1 and
yeah it's still still probably a
position where anything can happen
so
all right well i guess i'm fortunate to
receive the gift of king c3
and uh yeah i should probably go find
some food and take a nap before the next
round so
thanks everyone for watching i
appreciate all the positive comments and
feedback
on the first round video
stay tuned for more chess
and if you have any questions about this
game leave them below alright see you
guys